bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france vous avez rencontré le ministre
de la santé lors de son déplacement en
martinique que lui avez-vous dit
je lui ai dit que s'il fallait déjà
merci à la solidarité nationale parce
que il faut bien se rendre compte que la
martinique fait partie de la france et
merci à tous les soignants qui sont
venus apporter du renfort à des équipes
hospitalières fatigué et j'ai dit
personnel motion billy qu'il fallait pas
oublier les libéraux parce que les
libéraux sont les premiers acteurs sur
le terrain l'hôpital soit 17% de la
population et 95% sont pris en charge
par les libérons les infirmiers les
médecins qui sont leurs cabinets qui
sont eux aussi fatigué donc c'est un
travail de tout un travail de vous avez
exposé dans votre cour dans votre
reportage il faut convaincre plutôt que
contraindre donc c'est un travail qui
doit se faire à tous les étages par la
proximité par là les verts avec des gens
qu'ils ont confiance donc les médecins
sont le premier recours en tant que
médecin généraliste on doit expliquer
pourquoi pour se faire vacciner est
actuellement malheureusement nous
explorons énormément de morts donc pour
vous donner quelques chiffres au 4
juillet la martinique déplorait 92
humeur de l'aco vide actuellement au 13
août nous en sommes à
212 pardon 210 morts dont vous voyez une
explosion plus de 90% en rang du 15
juillet au 10 août au 12 août donc nous
sommes notamment sur une explosion
donc je pense que le message à faire
passer et que la vaccination est vite de
mourir du coc vite on qu'une personne
qui est actuellement en réanimation dans
les antilles n'a été vaccinées donc
maintenant il ya une prise de conscience
de la population parce qu'on écoute vous
savez nous non les avis de décès on a
tous les jours et elle a la liste
s'allonge je viens carminat donc les
personnes connaissent des personnes qui
sont décédées et r nous avons eu à
déplorer
avant-hier le 1er mai tous décédés
donc il faut vraiment que nous soyons
tous solidaires à chaque à chaque
échelon donc j'ai rasé riquet
comment gérez vous acceptez la situation
dans laquelle se trouvent les antilles
c'est essentiellement la conséquence de
la de la virulence du variant delta le
ministre de la santé a déploré le fait
et vous l'avez rappelé que les patients
hospitalisés aujourd'hui ne soit pas
plus vaccinée que vous disent les
patients que vous recevez dans votre
cabinet pour quelle raison est ce qu'ils
n'ont pas recours à l'injection antico
vide
là on a eu une augmentation de plus de
25% la vaccination donc je pense que la
marque n'a pas été impacté la marque
impacté par la première vague donc
les gens n'ont pas eu conscience de ce
qui se passe est donc actuellement la
vaccination doit se développer et il ya
une prise de conscience de la population
martiniquaise de l'impact
qui
les dessert quelque chose qui se
comptabilise donc là maintenant il ya
une prise de conscience de la population
avec en étant effrayer mais quand on
voit donc merci à différentes formes en
oeuvre des militaires nathan nous a
demandé des renforts de soignants de
l'hexagone et là on est interrogé par le
patient au quotidien en disant mais
docteur qu'est ce que vous en pensez ben
oui donc quand on écrit qu'actuellement
nous sommes obligés de faire des tris
d'hôpital obligés de faire des tris l
hôpital de choix de passion tout sur
l'écomobilité fonction de l'âge vincent
interpelle donc là il ya une prise de
conscience pourquoi elle n'a pas été
fait avant parce qu'on a été triple
attaque t on à 10 kg mais qu'on ne tente
pas notre système moi on va voir aya
verts on sent qu'on sentait apte à
former la
population se sentait pas forcément
concernés le relâchement des gestes
barrières peut-être est-ce que la
situation
extrêmement préoccupante aujourd'hui et
en martinique et peut-être aussi le
résultat d'un sous équipement médical
dont souffraient déjà la martinique
non je ne pense pas que ce soit la
conséquence d'un truc et qui pendent
médical elle a été la conséquence d'une
non vaccination et ensuite
était en marche il y ait tout au moins
on n'était pas impacté par le viril
delta et que le contamination
autochtones par un relâchement des
gestes barrières les gens des envies
voilà de faire la fête de la musique le
de cela chez les jeunes et la
contamination attaqué par les jeunes
maintenant la martinique nous sommes à
50 % du variant delta qui est beaucoup
plus contagieux alors que la guadeloupe
est à plus de 80% du variant delta donc
là nous sommes en phase exponentielle ne
sommes pas au sommet de la vague donc au
nous y serons dans quinze jours et le le
missel outre-mer ministre de la santé
aura près tous les deux complices de la
santé puisque c'est de sa compétence en
disant que j'aurais un roulement dans
les écrits de la première équipe de
renfort est arrivé pour 15 jours et on
va avoir une seconde activité est ce que
j'ai demandé au ministre était de
s'occuper aussi les libéraux qui sont
épuisés donc pour avoir à en former qui
libéral pour pouvoir avoir des relais on
qui dans les cabinets médicaux de
radiologie de mme étrangères a dit
d'avoir des renforts parce qu'on ne leur
a besoin actuellement les renforts sont
sur l'hôpital et on a entrant à
l'hôpital est en train d'armer plusieurs
lits de réanimation avec l'hôpital du
carbet qui va fermer l'hôpital du marin
qui est en ma douce aux hôpitaux
et il ya de la formation je voulais vous
portez c'est que samedi il va y avoir
une évacuation sanitaire de patients
vers la métropole avec les patients qui
vont partir vers l'hexagone merci
beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de réagir
sur notre antenne mancry keyyo rappelle
que vous êtes médecin présidente de
l'union régionale des médecins libéraux
de martinique